Professor Donald
Kagan: Why aren't you all
home like the rest of the class?
My subject today is Pericles as
general.
I don't expect that it will
take up all our time.
So, if you like when I'm
through I'd be glad to respond
to any questions or comments
that you want to make about the
Peloponnesian War.
So, if you think of any as I'm
talking, I hope you'll have a
shot at it.
Near the end of his
biography of Pericles,
Plutarch describes this great
Athenian leader on his death
bed.
The best men of Athens and his
personal friends are gathered in
his room and are discussing the
greatness of his virtues and the
power he held.
Thinking he was asleep,
they added up his achievements
and the number of his trophies,
for as general he had set up
nine commemorating a victory on
behalf of the city.
Now, we are inclined to
think of Pericles primarily as a
great political leader,
a brilliant orator,
a patron of the arts and
sciences, the man whose work in
the peaceful arts shaped what is
often called the Golden Age of
Athens.
So, it's useful for us to
remember that the office to
which the people elected him
almost every year for some
thirty years,
from which he carried on all of
these activities,
was that of strategos,
a general and that foremost
responsibility of Athenian
generals was to lead armies and
navies into battle.
From his own time until modern
times, Pericles' talents as a
general have been criticized and
defended.
In the first year of the
Peloponnesian War,
when his strategy called for
the Athenians to huddle behind
the walls of their city while
the invading Peloponnesian army
ravaged their lands in Attica,
Thucydides says the city was
angry with Pericles.
They abused him,
because as their general he did
not lead them out into battle
and they held him responsible
for all they were suffering.
In the next year,
after another invasion and
destruction of their crops and
farms,
and after a terrible plague had
struck the city,
again, Thucydides says they
blamed Pericles for persuading
them to go to war and they held
him responsible for their
misfortunes.
At a lower level,
the poet Hermippus,
one of the comic poets whose
work we don't have but
occasionally we have a quotation
and here's one.
Hermippus presented one of his
comedies in the spring of 430,
the second year of the war,
that simply charged Pericles
with cowardice.
He addresses Pericles as
follows: "King of the satyrs,
why don't you ever lift a spear
but instead only use dreadful
words to wage the war,
assuming the character of the
cowardly Telius.
But if a little knife is
sharpened on a wet stone you
roar as though bitten by the
fierce Cleon."
Cleon, as you know,
was his major opponent in the
last years of his life and Cleon
was hawkish and an advocate of
aggressive active fighting.
Now, the title of this talk,
Pericles as General,
is also the name of the most
vehement modern attack on
Pericles as a general.
I say modern,
of course, I'm talking about
the nineteenth century.
When you're an ancient
historian things take on those
proportions.
The author, Dr.
Julius von Pflugk-Harttung,
was a veteran of the
Franco-Prussian war and an
appreciative student of what he
took to be the lessons taught by
the great military historian and
theorist Clausewitz.
He believed that he had
acquired some useful knowledge
of the science of war,
as he put it,
that led him vigorously and
entirely to condemn Pericles'
generalship,
and Pericles' conduct of the
Peloponnesian War.
He says that we see
expeditions without inner unity,
without the possibility of
greater results,
and I'm quoting Pflugk-Harttung
now.
"To avoid danger,
Pericles regularly gave away
important advantages.
Overall, we find the effort to
lose no battle but nowhere to
win one.
As much as Pericles' personal
courage operated in battle and
in the assembly,
so little did he have of the
courage proper to a general,
which boldly risks the life of
thousands at the decisive
moment.
As such, he belongs to those
when they say a philosophical
group which brings everything as
neatly as possible into the
system and plan,
instead of acting openly and
vigorously.
It is a fact that Pericles,
the chief advocate of the
anti-Spartan policy never
offered a single battle against
the Spartans."
At the higher level of
strategy, the critique of
Pericles is no less severe.
"Pericles was a good minister
of war who made farsighted
preparations,
but as general,
he did not know how to make
good use of the existing
situation."
Again I quote,
"He was a great
burgermeister," this
means mayor.
It was not a very friendly
thing to call the great general
who led Athens.
"He was a burgermeister
in the true sense of the word;
there is the rich many
sidedness of his nature which
was then by that which came into
play.
His superiority to corruption,
everything petty and paltry,
yet he lacked the prophet's
vision and the certain luck of
the borne statesman.
Above all, he lacked the
recklessness which is often
needed to lead what has begun to
the goal.
As the leader of foreign policy
he was not comparable to a
Themistocles,
as a general not even
approximately to a
Cimon."So,
that's the harshest of the
critics of Pericles over the
years, but Pericles has been
very lucky over the years in his
defenders.
In antiquity,
his performance was justified
and praised by Thucydides,
who was after all a
contemporary,
a general himself,
and the historian of the period
whose interpretations have
dominated opinion ever since he
wrote.
For all the objectivity of
Thucydides' styles,
he tells the story very much
from Pericles' viewpoint.
For instance,
when he describes the revolt
against the Athenian leader in
the second year of the war,
and the Athenians' unsuccessful
effort to make peace,
this is how he describes the
aftermath.
"Being totally at a loss as
to what to do,
they -- the Athenian people --
attack Pericles,
and when he saw that they were
exasperated and doing everything
as he had anticipated,
he called an assembly,
since he was still general;
he wanted to put confidence
into them and leading them away
from their anger to restore
their calm and their courage."
He reports three of Pericles,
that is to say Thucydides does,
reports three of Pericles'
speeches at length without
reporting any of the speeches
made by his opponents on those
occasions,
with the result that the reader
is made to see the situation
through Pericles' eyes.
Finally, he makes his own
judgment perfectly clear;
coming down firmly and
powerfully on the side of
Pericles and against all of his
critics.
Here's what Thucydides
says, "As long as he led the
state in peace time he kept to a
moderate policy and kept it
safe.
It was under his leadership
that Athens reached her greatest
heights, and when the war came
and it appears that he also
judged its power correctly.
Pericles lived for two years
and six months after the war
began, and after his death his
foresight about the war was
acknowledged still more.
For he had said that if the
Athenians stayed on the
defensive, maintained their
navy,
and did not try to expand their
empire in wartime thereby
endangering the state,
they would win out.
But they acted opposite to his
advice in every way,
and when their efforts failed
they harmed the state's conduct
of the war."
Now, in spite of his
successor's departure from his
strategy and the disasters that
resulted in spite of the entry
of the Persian Empire into the
enemy ranks,
the Athenians held out for ten
years after the disastrous
Sicilian Expedition and for
twenty-seven years with
interruption altogether.
Here's Thucydides final word on
this subject,
"So more than abundant was
Pericles' reasons for his own
predictions that Athens would
have won in a war against the
Peloponnesians alone."
Thucydides makes it absolutely
clear;
Pericles was right in the
strategy that he had adopted,
and if the Athenians had stuck
to it they would have won the
war.
Plutarch accepted Thucydides'
judgment and added further
defense against the charges of
cowardice and lack of enterprise
that his enemies were launching
against Pericles.
To Plutarch,
the actions that provoked such
accusations instead revealed
prudence,
moderation, and a desire to
protect the safety of Athenian
soldiers.
In 454, we're back now in the
first Peloponnesian War,
Pericles led a seaborne
expedition into the Corinthian
Gulf.
Thucydides merely reports that
he defeated the Sicyonians in
battle and ravaged the territory
and besieged the important city
of Oeniada,
though he failed to take it and
then sailed home.
Obviously, answering later
criticism, Plutarch concludes
his account of these events by
saying that Pericles returned to
Athens,
and now I quote him,
"Having showed himself to be
formidable to the enemy but a
safe and effective commander to
his fellow citizens,
for no misfortune struck the
men on the expedition."
In 437, he sailed into the
Black Sea on a mission of
imperial consolidation that
amounted to little more than
showing the flag to the local
barbarians.
An action that was too
insignificant to be even noticed
by Thucydides,
but Plutarch does not miss the
chance to meet the criticism
that had been directed against
his hero.
On this campaign,
according to Plutarch,
Pericles displayed the
magnitude of his forces and the
fearlessness and confident
courage with which they sailed
wherever they liked and placed
the entire sea under their
power.
In 446, when Boeotia was in
rebellion, the bold and
ambitious General Tolmides
convinced the assembly to send
him at the head of an army to
put down the uprising.
Plutarch reports that
Pericles tried to restrain and
to persuade him to end the
assembly,
making his famous remark that
if he would not listen to
Pericles he would not go wrong
in waiting for time,
the wisest counselor,
but Tolmides didn't listen and
he went, and the result was a
disaster.
The Athenians suffered many
casualties, Tolmides was killed,
and Boeotia was lost.
Plutarch's comment is that this
incident brought great fame and
goodwill to Pericles as a man of
prudence and patriotism.
Later in the same year,
rebellion broke out in Euboea
and Megara revolted opening the
road for a Peloponnesian
invasion of Attica.
Pericles, on this occasion had
no choice;
he led an Athenian army out to
meet the invading army,
but instead of fighting a
battle he convinced the Spartans
to withdraw and then to
negotiate a peace.
In retrospect,
no doubt, his critics accused
him of missing a chance for
victory in the field.
Thucydides reports the
Peloponnesian withdrawal without
comment or explanation.
But Plutarch uses this action
to respond in almost poetic
language to later charges that
accompany the Peloponnesian
invasion in 431.
Reporting that his enemies,
Pericles' enemies,
threatened and denounced him
and choruses sang mocking songs
to his shame,
and insulted his generalship
for its cowardice and for
abandoning everything to the
enemy.
The Peloponnesians,
Plutarch tells us,
expected the Athenians to fight
out of anger and pride.
But to Pericles,
it appeared terrible to fight a
battle against 60,000
Peloponnesian and Boeotian
hoplites,
for that was the number of
those who made the first
invasion.
I'm still quoting Plutarch,
and to stake the city itself on
the outcome.
He reports Pericles'
calming language to the excited
Athenians in 431 saying that
trees,
though cut and lopped,
grew quickly,
but if men were destroyed it
was not easy to get them back
again.
Here he turned to the charges
of cowardice and lack of
enterprise and he turned them on
their heads and did so more
fully in a passage that sums up
his view of Pericles'
generalship,
and I'll read it to you.
"In his generalship he was
especially famous for his
caution.
He never willingly undertook a
battle that involved great risk
or uncertainty,
nor did he envy or emulate
those who took great risks with
brilliant success and were
admired as great generals.
He always said to his fellow
citizens that as far as it was
in his power,
they would live forever and be
immortals."
Of the many modern scholars who
have been persuaded by this
view, none has argued more
forcefully in favor of Pericles'
generalship than Hans Delbruck,
perhaps the most renowned
military historian of his day,
and still a respected figure in
that field.
He and Pflugk-Harttung were
contemporaries,
they lived in--well,
they did their writing on this
subject in the last decades of
the nineteenth century.
Annoyed by the critiques
rather, lately leveled at
Pericles and especially by
Pflugk-Harttung,
he wrote a thorough defense in
1890 under the title,
The Generalship of Pericles
Explained Through the
Generalship of Frederick the
Great.
His main effort and at work
is to justify Pericles' conduct
of the war that began in 431,
the subject of the greatest
criticism leveled at the
Athenian general.
Pericles' strategy did not aim
at defeating the Spartans in
battle, but was meant to
convince them that war against
Athens was futile.
His strategic goals,
therefore, were entirely
defensive.
He told the Athenians that if
they would remain quiet,
take care of their fleet,
refrain from trying to extend
their empire in wartime and so
putting their city in danger,
they would prevail.
The Athenians were to reject
battle on land,
abandon their fields and homes
in the country to Spartan
devastation, and retreat behind
their walls.
Meanwhile, their navy would
launch a series of commando
raids on the coast of the
Peloponnesus.
This strategy would
continue until the frustrated
enemy was prepared to make
peace.
The naval raids and landings
were not meant to do serious
harm, but merely to annoy the
enemy and to suggest how much
damage the Athenians could do,
if they chose.
The strategy was not to exhaust
the Peloponnesians physically or
materially, but psychologically.
No such strategy had ever been
attempted in Greek history,
for no state before the coming
of the Athenian imperial
democracy ever had the means for
trying such a strategy.
To do so was not easy.
For this unprecedented strategy
ran directly across the grain,
as you know,
of Greek tradition.
Willingness to fight,
bravery, and steadfastness in
battle, became the essential
characteristics of the free man
and the citizen.
Pericles' strategy of
passivity, therefore,
ran counter to the teachings of
the Greek tradition.
But most Athenians were
farmers, whose lands and homes
were outside the walls.
The Periclean strategy required
them to look on idly while their
houses, crops,
and vines, and olive trees were
damaged or entirely destroyed.
In the face of these facts,
as well as of the power of
tradition, and the cultural
values of the Greeks,
it is hard to understand even
in retrospect how Pericles could
convince the Athenians to adopt
his strategy.
Delbruck keenly aware of
Athens' numerical inferiority on
land was convinced of the
soundness of Pericles' approach.
Here's what Delbruck wrote,
"The structure of the
Peloponnesian War obliges us to
give him a position not simply
among the great statesmen,
but also among the great
military leaders of world
history.
It is not his war plan as such
that bestows this right on him,
for the fame of the commander
is gained not by word but by
deed,
but rather the gigantic power
of decision that accompanied it.
Not to halt with a half measure
but to plunge in whole heartedly
and to give up completely what
had to be sacrificed -- the
entire Attic countryside.
In addition,
the strength of personal
authority that was able to make
such a decision understandable
to a democratic national
assembly and to gain their
approval.
The execution of this decision
is a strategic deed that can be
compared favorably with any
victory."
Take that, critics.
Delbruck was pulling no punches
and if you said he was a bum I
say he was the greatest.
Delbruck tries to bolster his
case by comparing Pericles with
Frederick the Great,
King of Prussia in the
eighteenth century.
During the Seven Years' War
Frederick applied what Delbruck
calls a strategy of exhaustion;
instead of the strategy of
annihilation in which one army
seeks out the other to bring it
to decisive battle with the goal
of destroying its nation's
ability to resist.
Such a strategy is sometimes
adopted by or forced upon the
weaker side in a conflict,
because no other choice
promises success.
In the twentieth century,
the North Vietnamese communists
used it with success against the
United States.
Superior fire power brought the
Americans victory in set
battles, but was not so
effective in dealing with
various forms of guerilla
warfare.
The communists,
therefore, usually avoided
battles throughout the war.
Continuing warfare over years
without a decisive result fed
division and discontent in
America and ultimately exhausted
the American will to fight.
In the Second Punic War,
Rome repeatedly suffered
crushing defeats in battle at
the hands of Hannibal.
The Romans, therefore,
chose the tactics of Quintus
Fabius Maximus,
avoiding battle,
harassing the enemy with
guerilla warfare,
until they grew stronger and
he,
far from home and cut off from
it by sea, grew weaker and was
compelled to withdraw.
Pericles' strategy,
however, was unlike these
strategies in many ways.
Unlike the Vietnamese
communists and the Romans,
he never attempted a set battle
on land.
The Vietnamese wore down
America's resolve by inflicting
casualties on their forces.
The Romans avoided battle only
so long as they had to.
Their ultimate aim was to
defeat the enemy in standard
battles, which finally they did
in Italy, Spain,
and Africa.
Delbruck's comparison with
Frederick's strategy seems to me
no less faulty.
The Prussian Monarch was driven
to it by combat losses in set
battles fought over two years
and by the absence of any
alternative.
He needed to avoid battle to
survive.
Only good fortune,
not calculated war plans could
save him.
Britain came to his aid with
financial assistance and then
the most incalculable of all
things happened,
the death of the Russian
Empress who was a great fan,
who was hostile to Frederick
broke up the coalition of his
enemies allowing him to escape
from the war unbeaten;
she was succeeded by a czar who
loved Frederick the Great and
thereby saved his neck.
The situation confronting
Pericles was entirely different
from these cases.
No helpful allies stood in the
wings and no fortunate accident
came to divide his opponents.
Since he avoided all fighting
on land against the Spartans,
he inflicted no casualties,
as the Vietnamese and the
Romans did.
They and Frederick moreover,
aimed finally at fighting and
winning battles when the odds
were in their favor.
The core of Pericles' plan,
however, was to avoid all land
battles to show that the
Peloponnesians could do Athens
no serious harm and to exhaust
them psychologically,
to make them see reason and
understand that their efforts
were futile and could not bring
them victory.
His plan did not work.
The element of chance,
the unexpected and incalculable
intervened against Pericles and
against Athens in the form of
the terrible plague that
ultimately killed a third of the
Athenian population.
Of course,
all this encouraged the
Peloponnesians who refused to be
discouraged and continued to
fight.
When Pericles died in 429 the
Athenian treasury was running
dry, his plan lay in ruins,
and there was no prospect for
victory.
Only when his successors turned
to a more aggressive strategy
did the Athenians level the
playing field and achieve a
position,
which allowed them to hold out
for twenty-seven years,
and indeed on more than one
occasion,
almost brought victory.
So, it's not surprising that
Pericles' strategy in the
Peloponnesian War has brought
criticism that raises questions
about his capacity as a military
leader,
even from sober and friendly
scholars.
Georg Busolt,
a very distinguished German
historian, regarded his strategy
as fundamentally right,
but even he thought that it was
somewhat one-sided and
doctrinaire, and in its
execution it was lacking an
energetic procedure and in the
spirit of enterprise;
that's from a very good friend.
Hermann Bengston,
as you can see,
the Germans have dominated this
entire field of discussion,
defends the plan against its
critics, but concedes that the
carrying out of the offensive
part of the plan appears to
modern viewers as not very
energetic and resolute;
I'll say.
Their influence no doubt,
these critics are,
by the knowledge that Pericles'
successors took some actions
that did not risk significant
land battles or numerous
casualties,
and yet produced important
successes.
In the spring of 425,
the brilliant and daring
general Demosthenes,
conceived and executed a plan
to seize and fortify the
promontory of Pylos at the
southwestern tip of the
Peloponnesus.
From there, the Athenians could
launch raids at will and
encourage the escape or
rebellion of the helots,
Sparta's enslaved population.
His success panicked the
Spartans who allowed several
hundred of their troops to be
trapped and captured on the
Island of Sphacteria,
just off Pylos.
He immediately proposed a
peace, which the Athenians then
refused.
Later in the same spring,
the Athenians seized and
garrisoned the Island of Cythera
just off the southeastern tip of
the Peloponnesus,
and immediately they began to
launch raids against the
mainland.
Thucydides reports that the
Spartans suffered what I think
of as pretty much a nervous
breakdown.
Here's the account
Thucydides gives,
"The Spartans sent garrisons
here and there throughout the
country,
deciding the number of hoplites
by what seemed necessary at each
place.
In other respects,
they were very much on guard
for fear that there would be a
revolution against the
established order,
and from every direction a war
rose up around them which was
swift and defied precaution.
In military affairs they now
became more timid than ever
before since they were involved
in a naval contest outside their
normal conceptions of
preparation for war,
and in this unaccustomed area
they fought against the
Athenians to whom the omission
of an enterprise was always a
loss in respect to what they had
expected to achieve."
In other words,
whatever victories the
Athenians won,
however great,
they were always disappointed,
because they had expected more
than that.
At the same time the
misfortunes that had struck them
in such numbers,
unexpectedly and in such a
short time,
caused great terror and they
were afraid, the Spartans were,
that another calamity might
against strike them sometime,
like the one on the island of
Spachteria.
For this reason they were less
daring in going into battle,
and they thought that whatever
they undertook would turn out
badly,
because they had no self
confidence as a result of having
little previous experience with
misfortune.
Let me just remind you of the
enormous confidence with which
they entered the war thinking
that it would be no problem at
all,
all they had to do was walk
into Attica, and either the
Athenians would come out to
fight them as they had done the
last time and be destroyed
immediately,
or they would surrender rather
than see their lands destroyed
and look to what they had been
reduced,
not by Pericles' strategy of
exhaustion, but by the rejection
of that strategy and the effort
at a more aggressive approach.
In the light of results
such as these,
it is natural to ask why did
the enterprises that produced
these successes,
why did they need to wait until
the fifth year of the war?
Why didn't Pericles use them at
once?
His failure to do so is the
most weighty of the charges
brought against him,
and Delbruck uses much effort
and ingenuity to defend him.
He is forced to concede,
however, that a more
aggressive, offensive effort
would have been helpful.
He believes that the attack
Pericles led against Epidaurus
in the second year of the war,
in 430, was meant to take and
hold that city.
Quote from Delbruck,
"If any such conquest had
succeeded, any success in
Acarnania,
any campaign of devastation,
however intensive,
any fortification of a coastal
spot in Mycenae would disappear
in comparison."
Taking Epidaurus,
he says, would have threatened
the neighboring states near the
coast,
it might bring peace at once,
or at least cool the ardor for
war amongst Sparta's allies.
So, why did Pericles wait
and then do so little?
Delbruck's answer is "we do not
know."
The failure by so learned,
clever, and determined a
scholar and by as many other
defenders to explain Pericles'
behavior in this way,
I think, is a powerful sign
that they have taken the wrong
path.
Pericles did not mean to use
any serious offensive measures
to wear down the enemy's ability
to fight.
His goal, as I have said
before, was psychological and
intellectual.
To convince the Spartans and
their allies that victory was
impossible, that the Athenians
could easily sustain the only
damage the enemy could inflict,
the ravishing of Attica,
and to show to them and the
allies that the Athenians could
do them considerable harm,
if they chose.
Athens' carefully calculated
limited offensive efforts were
meant to deliver a message
without inciting the enemy to
fight and to fight harder.
Just as the carefully
calculated limited attacks by
American forces against North
Vietnam,
aimed at putting pressure on
the enemy, without causing their
Chinese supporters to intervene,
that kind of strategy calls for
very delicate action and very
delicate judgment,
and of course there's no
guarantee that it would work.
The offensive part of Pericles'
plan was deliberately to do
little harm.
For actions that were too
aggressive might anger the enemy
and harden his determination.
The goal was to depress the
enemies' spirit by showing that
there was no way for them to
win, to destroy their will to
fight.
Just a little footnote here,
that's always a critical issue
in any strategy that anybody
adopts in a war--really,
the two fundamental goals and
they do not always produce the
same strategy.
One is to make it impossible
for the enemy to fight,
to destroy his capacity to
fight, if you do that you have
certain victory.
The other is to destroy his
will to fight,
and of course if you do that
you win, but his will may not be
responsive to your approach.
If they could destroy the
Spartan will,
they could be expected to make
a negotiated peace that would
return to the status quo before
the war,
only made more secure by the
demonstration that it could not
be overthrown by force.
That was Pericles' aim in the
war.
That strategy failed,
as had Pericles' diplomatic
maneuvers in the period leading
to war from 433 to 431.
When civil war in Epidamnus,
a remote town on the fringes of
the Greek world,
threatened to bring a great war
between the Peloponnesian League
and the Athenian Empire,
Pericles, as I have argued to
you, pursued a policy of
restrained, limited intervention
meant to deter Corinth,
Sparta's important ally without
driving the Spartans and all
their Peloponnesian allies into
a war against Athens.
That effort also failed,
and resulted in a terrible war
that Pericles had wanted to
avoid.
Do these great strategic
failures fully make the case for
Pericles' critics?
Were they the result of
cowardice, lack of enterprise
and resolution?
I think that a fair examination
of his performance throughout
his life as general suggests
otherwise.
The charge of personal
cowardice is ludicrous,
even Pflugk-Harttung concedes
that his personal courage
operated in battle and in the
assembly.
No Athenian who led armies and
navies in many battles
repeatedly setting up trophies
of victory could have escaped
condemnation,
had he shown any sign of
cowardice, nor could he have
been re-elected general year
after year,
if that was the picture of him.
Nor did he fail to demonstrate
boldness and enterprise.
In 446, the very survival
of Athens and her empire were
threatened.
The most menacing rebellions
broke out close to home,
in Euboea, Megara,
and Boeotia.
Pericles swiftly took an army
to put down the Euboean
rebellion, and just as swiftly
withdrew on news of the second,
which opened the door to a
Peloponnesian invasion of
Attica.
He arrived, you remember,
just in time to persuade the
Spartans to withdraw and then he
returned at once to Euboea to
suppress the rebellions there.
Again, when the island of Samos
launched a dangerous rebellion
back in 440, Pericles took
personal charge,
acting promptly and decisively,
and catching the Samian rebels
unprepared for his swift
reaction,
taking them by surprise,
ultimately forcing them to
surrender by means of a naval
blockade.
These expeditions,
however, show that Pericles'
frequent caution did not derive
chiefly from a temperamental
tendency or a character flaw,
but from thought and
calculation.
The main reason he avoided land
battles against their Spartan
and Peloponnesian allies is
because he was certain to lose;
the numbers were decisively
against him.
Yet, he was more careful than
were bolder generals.
No polis in the Greek
world was prodigal with its
citizens in battle,
and it behooved the general,
especially in a democratic
state, to keep the casualty
lists as low as possible.
We need to remember that
Athenian generals were not only
military leaders but also
politicians, who needed to be
re-elected to their posts every
year.
No doubt Pericles sincerely
took pride in the prudence and
economy of his leadership,
but it could not have hurt his
political popularity when he
boasted to the Athenians what
I've quoted before that as far
as it was in his power they
would live forever and be
immortals.
Such considerations help
explain his cautious
performance, and yet there is no
evidence to suggest that he was
one of those rare military
geniuses who belonged in the
ranks of Hannibal,
Caesar, Alexander the Great,
a lesser but still worthy
example in our own time,
George Patton,
who understand the limits of
rational calculation and war and
the need boldly to seize
opportunity when it offers.
Pericles was what--a term that
was used in the Second World
War, a soldier's general as the
PR forces of Omar Bradley
attached that title to him.
He was no George Patton,
or perhaps, even a Bernard
Montgomery, who seeks battle
only when the odds are very
heavily in his favor.
He lacked the flair and the
boldness of a Cimon,
the daring and ruthlessness
that seeks victory at any cost.
Another element has been
suggested to explain the
Periclean strategy.
Pericles himself,
says one critic,
was rather an admiral than a
general.
The Athenian admiralty it was
which framed the strategy out
the outset of the war,
not Pericles the
burgermeister,
but Pericles the admiral
invented the strategy of
exhaustion,
a strategy which came near to
ruining Athens in a couple of
years and could never have won
the victory.
Well, there is some merit in
this analysis;
the Athenians under Pericles
had built a grand strategy that
was based on naval power that
might seem to suit a maritime
empire,
whose homeland was an island
such as Great Britain,
or a power that dominates a
continent and is separated from
other great powers by two great
oceans,
like the United States.
Athens' geographical
situation was not so fortunate,
for the city was attached to
the mainland,
offering targets of coercion
not available to the enemies of
the great Anglo-Saxon countries.
Pericles tried to cancel that
disadvantage by building the
long walls connecting the city
to its fortified harbor,
thereby in effect turning the
city into an island.
It was an extraordinary
strategy, far ahead of its time,
in its reliance on human reason
and technology and its rejection
of traditional ways of fighting
that cost lives and gave the
enemy an advantage.
At the same time,
he abandoned all ideas of
further expansion and devised a
policy aimed at preserving peace
and the status quo that
perfectly suited Athenian
interests.
Such a policy depended for
success on an extraordinary
amount of rationality on
everyone's part.
The Athenians must be content
with what they had and abandoned
hopes for extension of their
power.
There were always the
Athenians who objected to that,
but while he lived Pericles had
the wisdom and the political
strength to restrain and control
them.
What he could not control were
the other states and especially
the enemy.
Unexpected changes and shifts
in power are the normal
condition of international
history.
These changes have always taken
place, because international
relations are guided only
partially and spasmodically by
rational calculations of
material advantage.
Always at work as well are
greed, ambition,
jealousy, resentment,
anger, hatred,
and Thucydides' famous triad,
fear, honor,
and interest.
In the world,
as it has been,
therefore, a state satisfied
with its situation and wishing
to preserve peace cannot rely on
a reason that responds to its
reasoned policies,
but must anticipate challenges
that seem unreasonable.
The Spartans and their allies
ought to have recognized that
they had no realistic strategy
to promise victory over
Pericles' reliance on defense
and refusal to fight a major
land battle.
But resentment and anger at
Athenian power and the fear that
it might ultimately undermine
their own alliance and their
security led them to fight.
As I find it usual in human
history, they were more
influenced by the memory of the
Athenians' failure to fight a
traditional battle and
negotiating a peace in 446 than
by the recognition that the new
technology in the form of the
long walls made it unnecessary
for Athens to risk such a battle
in the future.
To deter a war in such
circumstances,
which is what Pericles was
trying to do,
requires some offensive threat
to the Peloponnesians,
whose menace was great and
impossible to underestimate,
that would make the fear of
immediate consequences of war
stronger than all the emotions
leading to war,
but Pericles had come to think
of Athens as an invulnerable
island since the acquisition of
a fleet,
a vast treasury to support it,
and defensible walls.
For such a state to adopt a
defensive strategy is natural.
It had developed a unique and
enviable way of fighting that
used these advantages,
and avoided much of the danger
and unpleasantness of ordinary
warfare.
It allowed the Athenians to
concentrate their forces quickly
and attack islands and coastal
enemies before they were
prepared.
It had permitted them to strike
others without danger to their
own city and population.
Success in this style of
warfare made it seem the only
one necessary and defeats with
great losses on land made the
Athenians reluctant to take
risks by fighting on land.
Offensive action,
in their view,
should be taken as a last
resort only;
only when it was absolutely
unavoidable.
Pericles carried this approach
to its logical conclusion by
refusing to use a land army even
in defense of the homeland,
much less by using it in
offensive efforts that might do
the enemy serious harm.
The enemy's passionate
refusal to see reason made what
might be called the Athenian way
of warfare inadequate and
Pericles' strategy a form of
wishful thinking that failed.
For a state like Athens in 431,
satisfied with the situation,
capable of keeping the enemy at
bay,
the temptation to avoid the
risks of offensive action is
great, but as people often don't
notice,
it contains great dangers.
It tends to create a rigid way
of thinking that leads men to
apply a previously successful
strategy,
or one supported by a general
theory to a situation in which
it is not appropriate.
But it may have other
disadvantages as well;
its capacity to deter potential
enemies from provoking a war is
severely limited.
Deterrence by standing behind a
strong defensive position and
thereby depriving the enemy of
the chance of victory,
assumes a very high degree of
rationality and some degree of
imagination on the part of the
enemy.
Spartans invaded Attica in 431.
They must have thought they
were risking little,
even if the Athenians refused
to fight,
even if they persisted in that
refusal for a long time,
both of which they thought was
unlikely and unnatural.
The Spartans would still be
risking little more than time
and effort.
In any case,
their lands and city would be
safe.
Had the Athenians possessed the
capacity to strike where the
enemy was vulnerable and had
that capacity been obvious to
everybody,
Pericles' strategy of
deterrence might have been
effective.
Once the war came,
there was no way to win without
abandoning the Athenian way of
war and the Periclean strategy.
As Pericles lay dying in the
fall of 429, his strategy was a
failure.
After three campaigning
seasons, the Peloponnesians
showed no signs of exhaustion of
any kind.
On the contrary,
they had just lately refused an
Athenian offer of peace and
fought on with the determination
to destroy Athenian power
forever.
The Athenians,
on the other hand,
had seen their lands and homes
ravaged repeatedly,
their crops and trees burnt and
destroyed.
They were also suffering from
the plague which was killing
great numbers of them and
destroying their moral fiber.
In the anecdote that I
quoted at the beginning of this
talk, Plutarch speaks of
Pericles' response to the praise
of his military prowess,
you'll remember.
He expressed astonishment--you
know they thought he was
sleeping, it turned out he
wasn't.
He was hearing what they were
saying.
He expressed astonishment that
they should be praising what was
the result of good fortune as
much as his own talents,
and what many others had
accomplished.
Instead, he said,
they should be praising the
finest and the most important of
his claims to greatness -- that
no Athenian now alive has put on
mourning clothes because of me.
That assertion,
the last words of Pericles
reported to us,
must have astounded his
audience,
even his friends would have had
to admit that his policy had
contributed, at least something,
to the coming of the war and
that his strategy had something
to do with the intensity of the
destruction caused by the
plague.
His final words show deeply
how he felt the wounds caused by
the widespread accusations
hurled against him and his
stubborn refusal to admit that
he had been wrong in any way.
He had applied his great
intelligence to his city's
needs, and reason told him that
he was not responsible for the
results,
which he must have believed to
be temporary.
He must have thought in time
his expectations would be
fulfilled.
If his fellow citizens would
have the wisdom and courage to
hold to his strategy,
they would win out.
So he believed and so did his
contemporary Thucydides.
More than two millennia
later, Clausewitz saw war
through very different eyes.
I quote him,
"War is more than a true
chameleon that slightly shapes
its characteristics to the given
case.
As a total phenomenon,
its dominant tendencies always
make war a paradoxical trinity
composed of primordial violence,
hatred, and enmity,
which are to be regarded as a
blind natural force.
Of the play of chance and
probability, within which the
creative spirit is free to roam
and its elements of
subordination as an instrument
of policy which makes it subject
to reason alone.
These three tendencies are like
three different codes of law,
deep rooted in their subject
and yet variable in their
relationship to one another.
A theory that ignores any one
of them, or seeks to fix an
arbitrary relationship between
them would conflict with reality
to such an extent that for this
reason alone it would be totally
useless."
Like most generals in
history, and unlike its few
military geniuses,
Pericles saw war as essentially
a linear phenomenon subject,
as Clausewitz said,
to reason alone and too little,
in my judgment,
did he understand its other
aspects;
for that he and his people paid
a very great price.
Okay, well, we do have some
time and I'd be very glad to
hear any questions or comments
that any of you'd like to make.
After all we only have a
twenty-seven year war and we've
got twenty minutes to talk about
it, no problem.
Anybody have anything to say?
Yes?Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Donald Kagan: That's a
fairly long story but I think
the best answer I can give is
the one I gave last time when I
spoke about Thucydides' reasons
for writing the story that he
did.
He had been a supporter of
Pericles and things hadn't
worked out well.
The state had gone a direction
very different from the one that
he favored, including a strategy
that was the opposite of
Pericles.
The average guy in the street,
who was a guy that he didn't
approve of very much,
thought wrongly,
he believed,
that Pericles had been dead
wrong.
It was Pericles' fault they
went to war, it was Pericles'
fault they lost the war,
and Thucydides associated
himself, I think,
with Pericles and his approach
to things,
and so he had to make the case,
that he believed the case that
he made.
I mean, it's very important
to realize that.
And Plutarch,
coming many centuries later,
like everybody,
who has ever spoken about the
Peloponnesian War,
once Thucydides had written,
was powerfully influenced by
Thucydides.
I think just about everybody
who has ever considered the war
has come away pretty much with
Thucydides' judgment of these
things.
So, I think that's the answer
to that.
Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Donald Kagan: The question
is, "can I think of any modern
generals who did use Pericles'
approach as a model."
I think the answer is not
anybody--well yeah,
General McClellan in the Civil
War and it was a very analogous
situation.
McClellan did not want to fight
Lee's army.
He wasn't all that crazy about
the anti-slavery stuff anyway,
but apart from that,
he didn't want to pay the
price, which was a tremendous
price fighting the Civil War and
so he wanted to avoid battle and
pretty much Lincoln couldn't get
him to fight.
So, that's one example.
Now, the next thing I would
offer you as something to chew
on at least--it is not
identical, it's only similar.
I think the strategy
undertaken by the Secretary of
Defense in the current
administration in launching the
attacks on Afghanistan and on
Persia--I mean Iraq.
I got Greeks on my mind;
I have to fight Persians.
Iraq reflected an aspect of it.
They were both,
for reasons I don't have to
explain to you,
desperately eager to reduce
casualties to a minimum and they
were desperately eager to choose
an approach that would limit the
time that the war lasted,
because of the political
situation in the last decades in
American history and they had an
advantage technologically that
seemed to make that
possible--America's fantastic
advantage in fire power,
the capacity to deliver the
fire power at a distance with
very little risk to the
deliverers,
with the notion of doing
tremendous harm when it got
there, but I don't know if any
of you remember any of this,
some of you were too young to
even think about it I guess.
Originally, remember--what was
that phrase that they had,
what was that great strategy we
were going to use by bombing the
hell out of the Iraqi's?
Shock and awe;
it was the same thing.
Shock and awe was meant to say
oh my God this is going to
happen to us and we quit,
was what they had in mind.
They deliberately chose not
to have ground forces that would
have been capable of doing the
kinds of things that it turns
out you need to do to be
successful in these wars just
like other wars.
So, when it happened that it
was clear things were not
working out, according to their
plan,
they stubbornly clung to that
plan, even as the evidence was
that it wasn't going to work.
So, that would be a candidate I
suggest.
Yes?Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Donald Kagan: Yeah,
the question is,
"do I think that recent
Athenian history or the
structure--you mean the
democratic society--the
democracy had anything to do
with the adoption of this plan?"
Perhaps.
You're absolutely right;
there must have been a very
clear and painful memory of what
happened to Tolmides,
when he invaded Boeotia.
There were very,
very heavy casualties there for
the Athenians.
That's the only one in which
they did have a lot,
but they did have those and
they were unusual.
So, it may have persuaded
Pericles that the Athenian
people would find it hard,
but on balance I really think
not.
I don't think that the Athenian
democracy was very different
from the oligarchies of the
other Greek cities in the way
they thought about things.
They would have much preferred
to fight it out.
It was only Pericles'
incredible command of the
political situation that allowed
him to take the strategy that
people said,
what in the world is this guy
doing?
They turned against it very
swiftly.
So, no I don't think that
democracy was especially
important.
Now, the enemies of Pericles
and the enemies of democracy--I
shouldn't say the enemies of
Pericles,
I mean the ancient enemies of
democracy do say that it was the
Athenian democracy's way of
running the war,
which guaranteed disaster and
they fix on something that comes
later down the road,
the Sicilian Expedition,
which was a dangerous
undertaking as it turned out,
although the Athenians didn't
think so at the time,
and they think only a democracy
could have done anything as
stupid as that.They are,
in that way,
following precisely what
Thucydides says,
but if you read my account you
will see that there's another
way of looking at it,
but that's what the ancient
anti-democratic view was.
Democracies are idiots;
they don't know how to conduct
war or do anything else right.
They will bring disaster.
I think you can get disaster a
lot of ways.
Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Donald Kagan: It's very
clear that so long as Pericles
was in charge everybody did what
Pericles wanted done.
Part of the reason was that we
know pretty well,
from the evidence that at least
a good number of the ten
generals in any one year were
close to Pericles,
so that his political influence
spread.
Very unusual thing in the
ancient world for anybody in
ancient Athens for anybody to
have that kind of a carry-over
effect,
but we see there's always
several generals that we know
are friends of Pericles,
and I think the rest of the
story is that you see the
generals don't get to decide
what they do in ancient Athens.
This is the part that blows
your mind.
When you send an army out,
that army gets a general or
more, it gets an assigned amount
of money and equipment and
stuff,
and it gets orders and all of
those things are decided by the
assembly after a debate by a
majority vote.
And what I would suggest to you
is that Pericles did not lose
any of those arguments,
except in the one case when
they came after him and nailed
him, and then they put him back
in office again.
So, does that take care of your
question?
Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Donald Kagan:
The heart of the question is,
"was Pericles wise to adopt a
strategy no matter how good a
strategy it might have been,
which he knew the Athenians
didn't like," and I think the
answer--well,
the outcome is obvious.
No, he wasn't wise,
but that's I think more because
the strategy was faulty,
not so much because the
Athenians didn't like it.
He had proven over the years,
and he proved now in the most
delicate of times,
that essentially he could get
the Athenians to do what he
wanted to do,
whether in fact they liked it
to begin with or not;
he persuaded them to do it.
So, I don't think that was
really a flaw.
The problem was that things
went wrong almost immediately
and then such terrible things
were happening as did shake his
power for awhile,
but even then he came back into
power and still his strategy
wasn't working.
I think the problem,
therefore--I think you could
say he knew what he was doing.
He thought he could get away
with it and he could have if the
strategy had been correct.
Yes?Student:
[inaudible]Professor
Donald Kagan: Oh yes,
yes, the question is ancient
writers--Plutarch is whom you're
really talking about.
They give Pericles credit for
being a great general,
but they say bad things about
Nicias,
who was involved in the great
defeat in Sicily and yet,
Nicias pursued something like
the strategy of Pericles,
which was avoiding these
conflicts.
I think the first thing I want
to point out is that Thucydides
didn't do that.
Not only does Thucydides
thoroughly support the strategy
of Pericles, he writes an
encomium on the death of Nicias
that raises him to the level of
Pericles or higher in his own
estimation.
But in the case of Nicias it
was, in a way,
even worse than what Pericles
did because Nicias,
first of all,
was against the war,
against going to Sicily in the
first place,
then when he was chosen to be
general he went,
but before he did that,
he tried to convince that
having lost the vote shall we
go.
He then decided to trick
the Athenians into not going
anyway by saying to them,
oh well, if you're going to go
all right, but it'll be
perfectly safe if you just sort
of take this--the original fleet
was going to have sixty ships
period.
Well, they ended up having a
130 ships, 5000 hoplites,
raising the risk of that thing
to the level that finally made
it seem like they could lose the
war by losing the Sicilian
campaign,
and he didn't--the Athenians,
instead of saying what he
expected, oh no,
no if that's what we have to
do,
let's not go,
Instead they said,
right on, yes you can have
everything you ask for Nicias,
what would you like,
and off they went.
Thereafter,
his performance on that
expedition is one of somebody,
who doesn't really want to
carry out his instructions.
What he would have liked to do
was, having lost the argument
twice now--he went out and did
everything he could to avoid
confronting any battle in
Syracuse and was finally driven
to fight at Syracuse,
very much against his will and
then I could go back and read
it, but he screws up the detail
of it over and over again,
and so I think there are good
grounds for condemning him as a
general, whereas,
the grounds on which Pericles
should be criticized,
I think, is as a strategist
rather than as a commander.
Anybody else?
Yeah?Student:
[inaudible]
Professor Donald Kagan:
No, but I think they--well,
I'll make one little exception
to that, but I think they could
have had a very good chance to
come out of the war in the way
Pericles hoped they would.
If they had pursued the limited
aggressive program that was
undertaken by Cleon and
Demosthenes after the death of
Pericles--so,
taking Pylos,
building a fort at Pylos,
taking Cythera,
building a fort there,
and perhaps even a few other
places on the periphery of the
Peloponnesus and launching
attacks from those places,
but not staying to fight the
Spartans at any great battle,
just causing that to happen.
If they had been able to do
that for a stretch of time,
then the hope that Cleon had
that the helots might escape to
these forts and ultimately bring
about an internal upheaval,
which the Spartans panicked
might happen,
would have led the Spartans to
offer peace,
and in fact they do.
The Spartans offer peace.
You could argue that if the
Athenians had simply accepted
the Spartan peace offer in 425
the war would have been over and
the Athenian Empire would have
been intact just the way
Pericles wanted it.
So, not only could they have
done it--and they would have
done it, if they had accepted
it.
They wouldn't accept victory
you could argue,
as many a scholar does.
The only other point I want to
make is after that didn't
happen, and finally a peace was
drawn up and signed and in
effect in 421,
which is another evidence that
they could achieve what they
wanted by the techniques that
were put forward,
but after that happened that
peace broke down and now the
Athenians found themselves part
of a new alliance of states,
Athenians with three
Peloponnesian democracies who
produce a big land battle in the
Peloponnesus and the Athenians
come--I mean,
the enemies of Sparta come that
close to defeating the Spartan
army in the Peloponnesus.
Had they done that,
they would have finished Sparta
off as a dominant power of the
Greeks.
So the answer is,
they actually had it in their
hands a couple of times and on
another time they missed by
about an inch.
Yeah they could have won that
way.
I think we're out of time.
Let me wish you all a very
happy holiday.
Bye-bye.